meet bob bob is an exceptionally average
guy who currently works in the taco bell
industry he's got some programming
skills he learned on youtube but has no
connections no social media following no
college degree and no trending apps on
the app store for some reason he wants
to work in the tech industry where he
can stare at a computer screen for 10
hours per day googling how to get his
code to work in today's video we'll look
at 10 powerful strategies that can help
you and bob land a six figure job by the
end of 2022 and i give you my 100 money
back guarantee all i ask is that you
like the video and subscribe and give me
10 of your salary before we get started
i want to point out that i've been
working independently for about a decade
so to make this video i reached out to a
few different hiring managers both at
big mega corporations and startups to
figure out what the decision makers are
actually looking for especially when
hiring a self-taught programmer with no
prior experience as of today the job
market is likely stronger than it's ever
been before there's all kinds of stories
of people quitting their jobs in the
great resignation only to land a much
higher paying job because there's a
massive shortage of talent that spans
across many industries it's really weird
and i've never seen anything like this
before it's great if you're looking for
a new job but there may be some warning
signs on the horizon many of the top
publicly traded tech companies have seen
their stock prices quietly crash over
the last few months companies like
twilio and cloudflare are down 50 from
their highs of last year a lot of big
money is moving out of profitless tech
companies and generally that's not a
good sign for tech jobs but that's just
a short-term concern over the long term
i think tech is one of the safest and
best places you could possibly work the
first thing you'll need is the right
attitude getting a high paying job in
tech is hard there's a lot of overly
optimistic marketing bs out there that
might make you think you just go to a
boot camp for a few weeks and
immediately after you're making a
hundred thousand dollars there are some
success stories that go like that but
for the most part it's a very difficult
grind that requires you to be highly
motivated and highly persistent to put
things in perspective lambda school who
recently changed its name to the bloom
institute of technology i wonder why
they did that charges 22 000 in tuition
but guarantees a job earning 50 000
after you graduate that's about what a
taco bell manager makes what they teach
you is the same stuff you can learn here
on youtube but they support you by
making you hirable the same thing i'm
trying to teach you on youtube for free
right now now if you don't get a job
after the program they will refund 110
of the tuition however in order to
qualify for that you'll need to spend a
year applying to 10 jobs per week
reaching out to 10 professionals for
networking and making at least five
github contributions that means you'll
need to apply to at least 520 jobs and
be rejected from every single one they
know it's a grind and you should have
the same mindset when going into it
yourself independently but on the bright
side it's definitely achievable if you
work hard at it and accept the fact that
you're probably going to have to face a
lot of rejection before you finally do
land a job i'd recommend subscribing to
the dorian develops youtube channel who
has a recent video about his story about
landing a job as a self-taught
programmer it took him about a year now
let's move on to strategy 2. live in the
united states specifically in new york
city the bay area or seattle in the 2021
stack overflow survey the median salary
for engineers is well below 100k in the
united states though it jumps up to
about 130k a few weeks ago i posted a
poll on this channel that has a 150 000
responses yet only 11 percent are making
more than 100k sadly where you live
really does make a big difference so
keep your expectations in line with your
region now the key to getting hired is
to make yourself valuable think of it
from the eyes of the employer why would
they actually want to hire you what
value would you add to the team to the
product to the company etc most tech
companies don't actually make any money
but the general idea of employment is
that the employer can make a profit off
of your labor the question becomes how
do we make you desirable to these
potential employers there are many
things you can start doing today in
strategy three we'll look at twitter
there's a whole subculture out there
called tech twitter and i've seen tons
of people land a job simply by adding
value to this tech twitter community
there's a pretty simple formula for
growing a twitter account to get started
follow the influential people that you
want to be hired by then create a
profile that's totally transparent that
you're on a journey to land your first
job in tech then you can start
responding to other people's tweets with
encouragement and positivity people will
think hey bob's a really nice guy i want
to see him succeed and i'm going to
follow him to watch it happen from there
you need to hack the [ __ ] out of the
twitter algorithm whenever you learn
something new post a thread about it if
you have any good code tips use carbon
to create a snippet and post it with a
bunch of emojis you'll also want to
create lists with resources for
developers like the best youtube
channels to learn programming and make
sure you put fireship as number one it
also helps to tweet out open-ended
questions and to come up with your own
memes the majority of my twitter growth
has been the result of memes if you're
serious you should be tweeting every
single day like multiple times per day
one account i followed tweets an average
of 37 times per day which generates an
average of 277 new followers per day you
don't need to be that prolific but just
try to be consistent more importantly
though don't screw things up by saying
something [ __ ]
like if you tweet out man my code is
being [ __ ] right now somebody with a
lot of followers who thinks they're a
lot more important than they really are
might call you out and then everybody
will dog pile on you and at that point
your journey into tech will be over
before it started now that you know how
twitter works let's move into strategy
four linkedin there are tons of
recruiters on linkedin who can help you
get a job in tech but remember bob
doesn't have any connections in tech yet
so how does he even get started with
linkedin well the first thing you can do
is find people you look up to and send
them a message that you're looking to
get into tech and that you would like to
connect most humans are actually pretty
nice and will connect with you no
problem feel free to make me your first
connection if you'd like also join
groups for the different technologies
that you're interested in and
participate in them if possible you can
also build your network by posting
content you can actually just reuse the
content you've been using for threads on
twitter and post it to linkedin now that
you have your linkedin network going we
can talk about the most important social
site in github as a self-taught
programmer it's very important that you
at least have something going on in your
github in a perfect world you have
commits every single day not only to
your own project but to many other open
source projects out there that's not
very realistic but it's important to be
consistent and that's exactly why lambda
school or bloom institute of technology
requires that you make five github
contributions per week to an employer it
shows that you're capable of writing
code every day which tends to be a
pretty important part of the job if
you're just getting started one of the
easiest ways to contribute is to look
for typos in the documentation fireship
io for example is open source and you
can find all kinds of typos in it if you
fix it and send a pull request you can
easily add that contribution to your
timeline as you start using more open
source libraries don't be afraid to open
issues when you find problems and if you
want to contribute look for issues that
are tagged with good first issue it is
true that you're kind of working for
free here but doing so will make your
github profile much stronger and it's
just great experience as a developer in
fact if you don't have fun doing this
kind of stuff then maybe a career as a
software engineer isn't the best career
path now that your github is impressive
it's time to build a personal project
because bob is a developer that nobody
knows he needs to show employers that he
can actually build something that's
non-trivial ideally something that will
blow people's minds that cannot be
ignored you are much better off having
one really awesome app than 10 mediocre
apps quality is much better than
quantity when it comes to your portfolio
the engineering manager who hires you is
likely a much better programmer than you
are they'll be able to tell if your
portfolio is filled with a bunch of
cookie cutter projects recreated from
tutorials on youtube give yourself three
to six months to build something that is
truly impressive one example is the
portfolio of bruno simon he used 3js to
build an interactive 3d landscape to
showcase his work the reaction from
other developers should be something
like wow that would not be an easy app
to pull off it's so good that i want to
include it in my youtube video building
an app is one thing but the next
strategy is to build this app in public
what i mean by that is you should
transparently document the entire
process while you spend the next few
months building something awesome the
most common way to do that is by
blogging there are many sites out there
like dev2 and medium to create your own
blog easily but i would highly recommend
blogging on your own custom built site
in my opinion a custom site expresses
more passion about the craft of web
development in addition to blogging
you'll also want to be documenting the
process on linkedin and twitter and you
may even consider starting your own
youtube channel building in public is
extremely powerful because it creates a
feedback loop you don't otherwise get
when you're just working alone in your
mom's basement there's a whole community
of startups who are building in public
you should give them feedback on their
products and in return they'll do the
same to make your project better in fact
you might even consider monetizing your
project because if you build something
really good you might end up
accidentally creating a job for yourself
one example of a success story is
superhuman an email application that
charges thirty dollars per month that
was built in public they got tons of
great feedback from potential customers
while building the product and you can
do the same thing with your personal
brand while looking for a job now we can
move into strategy eight real life
networking where you actually have to
like look at people's faces and say
words to them and stuff as an introvert
this has never come easy for me but what
i can tell you is that some of the best
business contacts i have come from real
life interactions believe it or not zoom
or the metaverse doesn't replace the
magic of face-to-face human interaction
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
the pandemic has ruined this in a lot of
ways but traditionally the best way to
meet people locally is through meetups
all you have to do is find your local
programming meetup show up there and eat
some free pizza and maybe you'll meet
someone important that can help you down
the road now the other thing i'd
recommend is attending conferences it's
more expensive but a lot of hiring
managers and employees attend these
things and they're often looking for
people to hire who are interested in
their tech stack learning the basic
skill of introducing yourself and making
small talk can go a really long way when
it comes to landing a job you just have
to get in a room with the right people
they say it's not what you know but who
you know speaking of which another
powerful strategy is to get a mentor
which is much easier to do when you make
a real-life connection it might be a
person with 20 years of experience or a
person that's just one step ahead of you
who just landed their first job it's
extremely valuable to have a person in
the industry who you can have an honest
conversation with you're likely making
many mistakes that you don't even
realize having a mentor who can validate
or criticize the things you're doing is
much faster than actually making those
mistakes and learning from them one by
one most boot camps will give you a
mentor and that's one of the main things
you pay them for but you'd be surprised
at how many people out there will mentor
you for free because at one point they
were in your shoes and people are more
altruistic than you might think and that
brings me to strategy number 10 be a
good fit as you start applying for jobs
you'll mostly hear crickets but if
you're lucky you'll get a phone
interview and then be rejected the next
day the natural reaction here is to be
sad and to feel worthless or you might
be angry at the company or think the
interviewer treated you unfairly but the
reality is that rejection is just the
story you tell yourself the best way to
respond to it is accept it as part of
life and selfishly see what you can gain
from it maybe ask for feedback or
guidance to help you do better next time
what you'll notice about successful
people is that they're persistent they
fail over and over again without caring
until finally something works now the
other thing to keep in mind is that a
company won't hire you based on your
technical skill alone i mean it
definitely helps but they also want to
make sure that you fit into their
company culture as a candidate they want
you to embrace their core values and
make sure that you'll fit into their
management leadership style before you
interview you should understand the
company's core values and look at their
social media profiles to see what kind
of messaging they're putting out there
make sure you align with their values
unless you want to hate your job for the
next 10 years and then try to mold
yourself into the candidate that they're
looking for i'd recommend also checking
out danny thompson's youtube channel who
has a short video that explains this
really well in detail and with that you
have 10 strategies that can help you
land a job you don't need to use all of
these but each one can get you a little
bit closer to landing a six figure tech
job in addition you'll also need to
learn how to code and how to master the
technical interview but don't worry i
have upcoming videos on those topics as
well make sure you're subscribed so you
don't miss them thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one